is the adoption of stable coins eating
away at potential adoption of Bitcoin
how do you view that relationship there
and is it a net positive or net negative
for Bitcoin I think it's not positive I
think it's harmonious Bitcoins are not
great as a payments Network people don't
want to be buying everyday things with a
unit of value that is fluctuating it's
the best store of value the world has
ever known in my view and it should play
that role and stable coins it's the best
payments Network in the world
all right guys bang bang I've got Peter
here with me Peter in our conversation
about stable coins I thought a perfect
place to start was just how big these
stable coins have gotten uh you all
recently put out a paper that talks
about 11 trillion dollars being settled
with stable coins in 2022. in context
that number is almost the same for Visa
what's going on and why are stable coins
so popular
yeah it's huge numbers I think it's
numbers that stun a lot of people and
the growth has been really incredible
it's great to be back on the show thanks
for having me on it was last time three
years ago talking about stable coins
um and back then stable coins were 6
billion outstanding they're now over 125
billion outstanding uh volumes at that
time were very very small and now like
you said their visa scale uh in the
amount of value that's being settled uh
on blockchains using stable coins and
that is just
on chain settlement that does not
include exchange trading volumes this is
actual on-chain settlement and it is as
you mentioned 11 trillion dollars last
year that is roughly the same as the
Visa Network and almost 10 times uh
PayPal for another sense of comparison
and another great statistic that Nick
Carter just put out is that actually 70
of the value that's transferred on
blockchains is stable coins so stable
coins are it's a killer use case it's uh
dominant use case frankly for
blockchains and and what we're seeing
here is that there is an insatiable
demand around the world for US Dollars
people want to save and Tran dollars
they want to transact in dollars if you
look at Commerce around the world the
vast majority of Commerce is already
done in dollars uh but there's also a
lot of people that don't have access to
dollars or using dollars is very costly
it's inconvenient it takes a significant
amount of time and with stable coins
it's an open network dollars that
effectively anyone in the in the world
with an internet connection can hold and
transact in a dollar and that dollar can
move around the world close to
instantaneously and close to free and
that is a very strong value proposition
for lots of people and businesses around
the world
so we're talking here about kind of how
popular they are by measuring
transaction volumes and obviously these
are stunning numbers uh I think for
people who haven't been paying attention
on a day-to-day basis but you also in
the report talk about 25 million
addresses having at least one dollar of
stable coin and so is that a proxy for
trying to understand the aggregate
number of people who are using stable
coins or how do you think about not just
transaction volume but actually how many
people or organizations use this stuff
right it's tough to get to the exact
number of users because when you look at
the on-chain data it's it's blockchain
addresses that you're looking at I do
think that is a it's a rough proxy for
the number of users uh users obviously
can have multiple addresses the flip
side of that is you're also under
accounting users that just use stable
coins via exchanges or custodial
Services
um but so the net result is it's
certainly imperfect but I do think it is
a rough proxy for a number of users and
as you mentioned there's 25 million uh
addresses that have at least a dollar of
stable coins so that I think that's a
proxy for usage and interestingly enough
out of the 25 most of those 20 million
addresses have between one and a hundred
dollars uh of stable coins so there's a
very large number of small dollar
holders and users
um when you look at how stable coins are
being used and then another way to look
at it is is how many of those addresses
are actually active because obviously
there could be you know people
um you know abandoned addresses or
forgot about them or whatever
um but there's a huge number of active
addresses and there's actually five
million uh addresses weekly active
addresses sending stable coins and that
is the um if you you know for folks that
have read the report that I just put out
on stable coins that is the chart we
started with is weekly active addresses
because the growth of weekly active
addresses using stable coins is then
Relentless it's up and to the right full
Market Fair market prices go up prices
go down it doesn't seem to matter more
and more addresses and effectively more
and more people are using stable
Bitcoins the growth is unbelievable
so when we see kind of ball and bear
markets one of the interesting data
points you guys point out is that stable
coins are decoupling from a lot of this
exchange volume so you're continuing to
see growth but also you're seeing that
even when there is some sort of decrease
in the market cap it's at a very
different uh kind of degree or severity
talk a little bit as to why do you think
this decoupling is happening is it
because the other assets are more
speculative in nature and this isn't or
is there some other reason
yeah absolutely I think that is what is
happening and that is one of the reasons
that we wrote this report we started
this report almost a year ago and the
the Genesis for this was that I was
hearing a lot of narratives and I'm sure
you hear these narratives as well
um and the two things that a lot of
people say are one is that crypto is
just for speculation it's all trading
it's all gambling there's no
quote-unquote real world use cases are
there very few a few of them
um and then the other one specifically
because stable coins is that as the
market cap of stable coins starting to
come down I started hearing people
saying like Okay stable coins it's not
working like this is not being used it's
a failed experiment
um those types of things and I did not
think that those narratives were true so
I wanted to dive into that and see okay
what what does the data tell us on how
stable coins are actually being used and
we saw as I mentioned the Relentless
growth of active addresses of
transactions of those types of things
but you will and we also saw as you
mentioned the decoupling of stable coin
volumes from exchange volumes Exchange
change volumes if you look at starting
at the beginning of 2022 by you know
when when things were were hotter in the
uh the crypto markets uh volumes on
centralized exchanges and decentralized
exchanges those are down about 60 or
more uh since that time period and
during that same time period stable coin
volumes are roughly flat and the number
of active wallets that active users
um are actually a number of transactions
uh are all up significantly so I don't
when you look at that data I think that
that is some of the most compelling
proof when you look at what's happening
with exchange volumes versus blockchain
stablecoin volumes I think the only
logical conclusion conclusion you can
take out of that is okay these stable
coins are being used for a lot of other
things and not just Trading
when we start to look at that
outstanding Supply right so if people
are using them and many of the data
points that you've highlighted here we
went from about three billion five years
ago to now 125 billion and in the report
you will talk about well actually it was
160 and now it's come down to that 125
billion so there has been some
contraction in the market but to me
getting it why is this happening right
how much of this is what I'll call like
demand lead growth where people are
basically just starved for Dollars
around the world or even in the United
States and they want to be able to use
it versus actually it's been
infrastructure building right we we see
a circle in usdc we see many other uh
payment processors and different
companies starting to add support for
stable coins like is it both is it more
demandled is it more kind of like Supply
and infrastructure like how do you think
about just like what's driving such you
know insane growth over the last five
years
it's tough to put your finger on what
exactly it is because there's so many
different factors as you said and the
growth of stablecoin says has it's
what's been in the driver's seat has has
varied over time and when stablecoin
started and you know tether got uh you
know tether got a lot of traction
starting in 2018 went from effectively
nothing to three billion dollars in
2018. that was all driven by exchanges
and
exchanges and Traders that didn't have
access to U.S bank accounts and wanted
to trade using a dollar based pair and
move dollars between exchanges and that
is what gave stablecoins the initial
growth and then what you had is you had
exchanges around the world add
stablecoin pairs so now you have
effectively anywhere in the world you
can go from a local currency into a
dollar via a local
cryptocurrency exchange so that
infrastructure build out has been it's
absolutely massive over the last several
years and that that infrastructure built
out was not built out to enable you know
stablecoin movement around the world it
was enabled to help these exchanges but
the end result of that is that we now
have a system where you can get to
Dollars and move dollars and get out of
those dollars and almost every currency
in the world quickly and cheaply and
then on top of that you have folks like
Circle and others that are building
infrastructure especially for stable
coins and then you have this whole
um
really explosion of companies now
they're building applications on top of
this specifically for stable coins
because the way that a lot of these
transactions work right now it is
between exchanges and people are using
crypto exchanges to do this but a crypto
exchange really isn't meant for if you
just want to save and spend and uh you
know in dollars in uh in stable coins
it's not something you're gonna
um you know recommend that your mom use
uh for example but now there are
applications that are being built
specifically for you know you're in
Latin America you're in turkey and you
want to save in dollars and you want to
spend in dollars we can make a great
fintech app that does all these things
and happens to use stable coins in the
back and is just a much more efficient
way to do it and it offers access to
more people and that's some of the most
exciting stuff we're seeing right now
yeah one of the pieces of the report
that frankly um it took me a while to
kind of think through like it makes
sense but it's also surprising is that
only about one-third of the stable coins
are on Exchange so on one hand it's not
a speculative you know asset and so
therefore an exchange usually people are
looking to trade or or kind of you know
make some sort of uh kind of speculative
action on the other hand only one third
being on the exchange like there's not
that many places to go get stable coins
other than on exchanges and so how do
you guys think through that and like is
that a bullish sign for stable coins is
that a negative or are you kind of
agnostic to that specific data point
yeah I think that that's a great data
point and that's actually the the data
point that we started with when we
started a lot of This research about a
year ago is that we're looking we're
trying to figure out like okay how are
state of coins being used is it
speculative is it non-speculative the
first thing we looked at is how much how
much stable coins are on exchanges
because I think I think that that's the
easy way if it's on an exchange it's you
know it's being used for trading if it's
if it's not it may or may not be
um but knowing how much is on exchanges
is certainly indicative and you know we
found as you mentioned that you know
less than a third of stable coins are on
exchanges and that number has been
coming down significantly now there's a
number of reasons that could be coming
down it could be coming down because
endorse more non-speculative use cases
it could also be coming down post FTX
people just don't want to leave their
coins on exchanges so it's not a
definitive fact but it's one of the as
we were triangulating how stable coins
are being used I think a very positive
data point in supporting the
non-speculative uses of stable coins
yeah that makes sense now I want to talk
about some of the Technologies here so
obviously tether is the most popular
stable coin and kind of has continued to
dominate the market I think usdc is the
second most popular and has had a great
run in terms of eating some market share
but still you know hasn't been able to
Eclipse uh tether and so some of the
data points that you all share is that
tether represents 69 of stable coin
Supply year to date it's accounted for
80 of weekly active addresses 75 of
transactions and 55 of volumes how much
of that is just like first mover
Advantage how much of that is uh you
know kind of having maybe a different
approach to whether it's technology or
what they're doing with some of the
assets and then how much of that is just
a moat and like it doesn't matter how
good another stable coin comes if you're
first and you've got you know kind of
the market dominance you kind of get to
do that unless you really really screw
it up this episode is brought to you by
auradon they are a brand new startup led
by a number of Silicon Valley Legends
who just raised 81 million dollars to
build the future of Internet
infrastructure you're probably wondering
what that means let me explain there are
numerous new disruptive technologies
that are being adopted simultaneously
from blockchain to artificial
intelligence to zero knowledge
Technologies in order to ensure that
these Technologies thrive in this new
world we need new infrastructure and
that is where ourdyne comes in they just
launched their first product line called
teraflux which is a Bitcoin miner
powered by the world's first four
nanometer silicon chip technology these
air-cooled single phase and dual phase
emerging cooling miners have unrivaled
speed and efficiency they have Superior
uptime and they leverage a brand new
innovation called Energy tune that
allows miners to dynamically adjust the
energy consumption and Bitcoin hash rate
based on demand response needs of the
electrical grids auradyne is an
ambitious company working on hard
problems I'm really impressed with them
and if you want to check out more you
can go to auradyne.com that's
a-u-r-a-d-i-n-e.com go check them out at
auradon.com today yeah I think a lot of
it is the first mover Advantage like
they were there first and they
established themselves in a variety of
of different ways they became the
dominant trading pair on a lot of
exchanges the majority of exchange
volume is denominated in tether so that
is a big advantage in a mode
in emerging markets around the world
people just started using tether when
you go to Latin America or other
countries and you ask people you know do
they use stable coins do they know what
stable coins are most the time they do
and they're most often using tether
ontron just because that was their first
it's what people used they've gotten
used to it they got comfortable with it
they're not thinking too much about
tether or the Tron blockchain it's just
that's the way they can access dollars
um so I think that the first mover
Advantage is a very big Advantage for
for tether and tether on Tron I I think
it will change over time I think that
uscc what we saw with usdc did gain
significant market share and started to
challenge each tether for a little bit
but then there was a what I would
consider as a series of unfortunate
about lines one is just the market cap
overall of stable coins coming down and
if you're looking to redeem a stable
coin go from a stable coin into a dollar
uh unfortunately or fortunately uh USBC
is much easier to do they have better
customer service it's easier to redeem
There's No Redemption fee that's very
important so if you're looking to redeem
which one are you going to redeem you're
going to redeem the one without a
Redemption fee so it's kind of natural
that more usdc is going to be redeemed
than tether and that some stable coins
are going to be redeemed as we go from a
zero interest rate environment to a five
plus percent interest rate environment
the value proposition for holding uh you
know your dollars in something that
doesn't pay interest it just gets
tougher uh so we saw flows out a lot of
those flows came out from usdc and then
on top of that the regulatory
environment has been tough in the US uh
you've had the svb collapse and even
though that ended up not
uh being an issue for Circle I did
people freaked out over that weekend
that significantly hurt their volumes
and their the value I was standing over
that weekend so I think that it is
um we were seeing what I thought was a
positive trend in usdc gaining share we
had a series of unfortunate events that
uh brought that share down but I do
think that usdc will if you actually
look at a lot of the underlying metrics
we Collective users transactions uh
volumes are actually popping back after
after the svb issue like I think that
they're on a good track and then the
PayPal entry is obviously just
absolutely massive these the scale of
PayPal the number of customers that they
have they already have 400 million users
uh they have hundreds of thousands of
merchants that are using PayPal uh and
they're they're trusted by everyone
there's a survey PayPal second most
trusted brand in the world uh in a
recent survey so so people around the
world trust PayPal and now you have uh
you can get a PayPal dollar anyone in
the world with an internet connection
can get a PayPal dollar like that is
going to be absolutely huge if PayPal
launch it and I think that they do I
think they're going to be measured in
how fast they grow because Regulators
don't want them to go too fast but their
entry is going to be uh I think it's a
game changer yeah that um that makes a
lot of sense now let's talk a little bit
more about Tron and binance smart chain
I think people who again haven't really
dug deep into uh stable coins haven't
read this report they're going to be
shocked by these statistics so 77 of
weekly active addresses uh of stable
coin activity cumber on Tron or binance
smart change 75 of transactions and 41
of volumes most people I think would
look at both Tron binance smart chain
and say oh that's probably some altcoin
thing like that has nothing to do with
day-to-day usage these statistics are
showing the exact opposite and I'll give
you an anecdote I talked to an
entrepreneur from Argentina recently and
he said that you know most people they
want dollars and they're not going just
to buy Bitcoin they want dollars and so
stable coins have had this huge rise in
popularity and they're using Tron and
when asked them why he said well it
settles quickly and it's cheap and it
was just like so simple it kind of goes
back to your point of like do people
care what blockchain they're using if
they can just get simple quick and cheap
transactions
I don't think so I think they think that
that is the the primary
um well the primary driver is that the
first mover Advantage is that we moved
from you know tether on tethering each
other on the Bitcoin network is where we
started then we went to ethereum and
then uh we moved to these faster and
cheaper chains and unfortunately the
first faster and cheaper change that
they went to were trying to BSC
um so you we got a lot of adoption there
and then once you can have a fast cheap
dollar transaction most users aren't
thinking too much about which blockchain
that's running on
um so we've seen this this adoption of
trying to BSD I think that will change
over time and if you dig in a little bit
further and you look at the sizes of
Holdings and sizing sizes of
transactions you actually do see that a
lot of higher value Holdings and higher
value transactions are on the ethereum
blockchain
um you know the average ethereum uh
transaction is um they don't have it in
front of me but something like 10 times
the size of a Tron transaction and
something like 70 times the size of a of
a stablecoin transaction on vse so you
are seeing the higher value transaction
and on average on ethereum which does
make sense because it's a more
decentralized blockchain with strong
settlement ensuring assurances Etc I do
think over time we're going to see much
more on other layer ones which are more
decentralized like Solana and then
certainly on on layer twos uh we're
seeing a lot of activity there now we're
already seeing stablecoin volumes
increased uh very dramatically on on
layer twos and I think over time we I
think we will and I certainly hope we
will move from chains like trying to BSC
to things like salon and layer tubes
talk a little bit about the stablecoin
issuers you know we've seen both tether
and uh circle come out and just report
monster quarters some of that is
obviously being held by interest rates
going up in a very aggressive manner but
these businesses are shockingly big how
do you guys evaluate is it sustainable
can competition eat away at some of
these profits what do you kind of
foresee Happening Here
yeah they are absolutely monsters in in
terms of profitability I think that's
another thing a lot of people from the
outside probably don't realize that you
have crypto businesses tether making a
billion dollars a quarter in in profit
like
that's incredible
um is that sustainable I don't think at
this level it's not sustainable I think
that they are going to one eventually
interest rates will come down somewhat
um and also there's going to be
competition from a number of angles one
of those angles will be interest varying
stable coins I think we're going to see
more interest varying stable coins uh
there are issues there from a regulatory
perspective that may be a security in
the US Micah in Europe uh explicitly
doesn't allow that but there's going to
be ways to pay interest on stable coins
and that will be a
um that will bring some of those margins
down and then I also just think you are
going to see more competition from new
entrants like PayPal I think other
entrants are going to come in and that
will put pressure on some of these
businesses but in general
this is a fantastic business especially
when rates are high you effectively have
zero cost deposits that you're earning
five percent on uh that's a great
business
talk a little bit about cbdc's and do
you see the private stable coins
competing with replacing uh could they
actually be hurt if Central Bank digital
currencies come out from either large
central banks how do you see these two
things interacting with each other
yeah Central Bank digital currencies is
not something that I think is actually
um
something that would actually happen in
most developed countries and most
central banks don't actually want to do
a retail cbdc
um if you talk to Folks at the FED they
have many times explicitly said they are
not looking to do a retail cbdc they
have no interest in doing that any cvdc
is more of a wholesale cbdc uh which
really at that point it's very similar
to what we already have in fed and fed
now so it's not disruptive to
um stablecoin issuers which are at a
retail level so I don't think I think
it's uh
is an interesting like thought
experiment for central banks to go
through the idea Mas and how how the
different ways they could potentially do
this but at the end of the day unless
you're going to go to China route and
really focus on surveillance
know where and how retail people are
spending all of their money it doesn't
really I don't think it's possible for
um
it's not it's not it's not it's not
practical for for most central banks to
actually issue a cbdc a ruby tell cbdc
one of the things I I've kind of done
the thought experiment on and I don't
know what the probability of this is but
it seems like if all of a sudden you
know out of the 330 340 million
Americans if you had more than 50 of
them using dollars with dollar stable
coins by a private company uh regardless
of who that company is does the
government all of a sudden say you know
what like uh that sounds like we should
own that or we should be involved in
that in some form or fashion
um again we have Banks obviously that
have users and use certain Technologies
but this feels like a little bit closer
to what the government historically has
enjoyed as their role in the financial
Market how do you see that relationship
so if the government doesn't issue a
cbdc but the private companies become
highly successful in getting adoption
does maybe the government's you know
kind of evaluation change
I think it will I think it should and I
think it will I think that we should be
passing uh Federal
stablecoin regulation right now there is
no reason that that is not passed I have
yet to hear a Coheed adherent argument
against a federal framework for
stablecoin issuance uh it's
I think it's shocking that we it seems
like we're not going to get that
legislation this year uh which is fine
we have stable coin issuers they they
operate under State Frameworks but we
should have a federal framework it
should be overseen by the FED they
should probably have fed accounts so
they can hold funds directly with the
fed and and that's where I think we'll
get to eventually I think we're still in
this in between phase which we often are
in crypto where people still think this
just might go away but hopefully you
know some you know folks will uh hear
you on cbdc and read my report and
realize you know stable coins aren't
going anywhere uh they're great for the
US by the way they they they encourage
the use of the use of the US dollar they
creates a new buyer for treasury bills
um it gives the U.S uh you know law
enforcement and Regulators more control
uh over them to to some extent
um I think that as that people come to
that realization we will get Federal
stable coin regulation which will be
good for the industry
my last question for you is the
relationship between stable coins and
take Bitcoin Bitcoin obviously in the
white paper talks about being electronic
you know peer-to-peer cash uh stable
coins seem to be the choice technology
today for a lot of these transactions
Bitcoin still has quite a bit of
transaction volume as well but is the
adoption of stable coins eating away at
potential adoption of Bitcoin are they
harmonious and and kind of actually help
each other and it's like all boats rise
together how do you view that
relationship there and is it a net
positive or net negative for Bitcoin I
think it's not positive I think it's
harmonious I think that the conclusion
that I came to a long time ago and I
think you did too is that Bitcoin is
Bitcoins are not great as a payments
Network people don't want to be buying
everyday things with a unit of value
that is fluctuating as much as Bitcoin
does and Bitcoin transaction times and a
lot of things about Bitcoin just make it
it's it's not a good uh payments Network
it's a good store of value Network it's
a fantastic store value in that group
it's the best store of value the world
has ever known in my view and it should
play that role and stable coins offer a
way for people to it's the best payments
Network in the world and that gets
people into crypto and once you're into
crypto I think that also opens you up to
okay now we want to store my some of my
wealth in a store of value that is not
subject to the government whims and
money Printing and all of those types of
things and once you go down that path I
think you will logically end at you know
things like Bitcoin maybe ethereum which
are great for portfolios offer
diversification all of those things and
I think that that is really the role
that they play much more so than um
being used for payments
Peter when you think about kind of the
work that you guys are doing how do
investment firms interact with stable
coins right is it something where you
can just store cash move it more quickly
maybe pay folks like how do you kind of
uh see the financial world not retail
but the actual financial institutions
interacting with these assets
yeah so uh Bremen heart digital were a
very large macro hedge fund
um with uh Bernhardt digital is our
crypto division
um in Burma Howard digital we obviously
we trade on many crypto exchanges so we
are dealing with stable coins
um all the time to move money between
exchanges uh you know on the Venture
side we will fund Investments with
stable coins
um so it starts to work its way into the
operations of trading firms
um in those types of ways and then I
think you will see more and more of that
like okay we're funding Investments with
stable coins are there other things that
we can do with it eventually again a lot
of that infrastructure needs to be built
up I think before that used in a more
widespread basis and I also think the
value proposition for stable coins in
the US is not the same as it is
internationally uh it's much it's a much
stronger value proposition
internationally in the US I have access
to Dollars my credit card works just
fine I I don't really need stable coins
frankly and you know Jeremy said 70
percent of usdc adoption is outside the
U.S tether adoption is much higher than
that outside the U.S and that's where
the real value proposition is and I
think that's also why a lot of people in
the US are surprised when you start
giving them these statistics is because
the value proposition doesn't resonate
with them the value proposition of
Bitcoin also doesn't resonate with
people in the US nearly as strongly as
it does over other parts of the world
because we have lots of store value and
our currency isn't having massive uh
inflation and all of these types of
things so I think that it's a um the U.S
development Market perspective on stable
coins on crypto is often very different
than it is in in other parts of the
world
I think that makes a lot of sense Peter
where can we send people to find you on
the internet or uh find out more about
Brevin Howard digital or even maybe read
the paper that uh that you just put out
uh yeah you can find me on Twitter I am
at the Chicago VC
um the paper is also posted on Twitter
so it's probably the easiest place to
find it awesome the the all-time Twitter
handle of the Chicago VC pretty clear
what uh what you're looking to do right
I uh I locked myself in there
awesome well thank you so much for doing
this we'll definitely do it again in the
future thanks Mom appreciate it